[Music]
pyrotechnician
we're gonna talk about some movie news
today a couple of box-office stories and
the Russo brothers said about the
soulstone here before going into that
I'm Paige from one of our waters is at
Google hangout over there we were doing
a Google hangout with a friend of ours
named Jason Dolan he's a working
screenwriter and we got to talking about
Kathryn Bigelow one point and vampire
stories he brought up this movie that
Kathryn Bigelow directed called near
dark while we were talking we were like
he's saying it's hard to find and then
while we were searching with him we went
on Amazon and it's the only copy that
has like 74 dollars or something no I
see a smoothie for some reason but he
highly recommended it come to our
surprise had no idea he was gonna do
this we got this in the mail from him
just a few minutes before film and I
opened up the box and he sent us a copy
of near dart
so Jason Dolan thank you so much for
doing that man this was something I was
tempted to be like just throw down and
buy this I just do anyway this movie has
been recommended to me for years man I'm
like I was I was bummed and shocked at
the same time to find out how hard it is
to get so I'm really excited to take a
look at this thank you so much Jason
that's like incredibly kind of you and
you are one charming good-looking man
you belong in front of the camera too
buddy we'll definitely get back to you
when we watch the film anyway let's move
on to some movie news now before going
into the big box office story I want to
briefly touch on this does this
surprised me actually I was genuinely
surprised so although a Star Wars story
might actually outdo both rogue one a
Star Wars story on its opening weekend
in pre-sales and it might actually
outperform Black Panther which is super
shocking to me because I was under the
impression a lot of people didn't really
care about this movie yeah and black
panther did extraordinarily well yeah
again that one-two punch I am very
skeptical of that because to me this
kind of registers as the hardcore
dedicated Star Wars fans are all gonna
be checking this movie out even though
there's been a lot of not-so-great talk
about it even the trailers and whatnot
there
forming well but they're not doing the
numbers like the last Jedi did or Black
Panther did so it's generally surprise
with us it could beat the Memorial Day
weekend record it's estimated beat out
parts of the Caribbean 3 indiana jones
for good for the movie what will really
tell about this film the excitement it
will be the word of mouth and how it
proceeds in next few weeks even if it
beats out the opening a weekend record
of free sales for Black Panther beats
out the Memorial Day weekend for rogue
one if it does all that
I mean kudos to the film will it cross a
billion I don't know I actually I
actually have a lack of faith that would
cross a billion unless it just happens
to just do a complete 180 and everyone's
like this is actually a really great
year film I'm not
I need stretch the mean scene it's gonna
be Ben if you watch any of our trailer
reactions we never say that we think
it'll be a bad movie we're always on the
side that looks like it'll still be a
fun enjoyable time will it outdo Black
Panther I don't think so at all
I don't think overall come close to
beating the box-office gross but it's
not about competition I was kind of
worried this film would just flop yeah
yeah I had that concern even though I'm
not like oh yeah solo I still didn't
want this movie to do bad I still wanted
it to succeed box office wise so based
off these Tracking's
it looks like it'll still make its money
back which is a good thing meaning they
won't slow down that star will restrain
that everyone seems that wanted to slow
down and not want her to slow down to me
they complain but they keep watching it
I don't know we wanted to slow down but
everybody freaks out every time there's
a new one anyway yeah matter how close
they are together and yeah this is a
movie that gives me an odd vibe because
on the one hand I'm like I guess I can
see it out matching rogue one because
rogue one had less familiar stuff to go
off of it's sort of like what is this
new Star Wars thing whereas solo is Han
Solo so I feel like you've got the
lackluster response but you've also got
the fact that it is like an iconic
character and yeah I don't I can see it
having a strong opening weekend I don't
think it'll set like a million box
office records beyond that though yeah I
don't even know if it will outperform
rogue one in the long run - because
rogue one was the first spin-off it was
still exciting there was still time
after force awakens we just got last
Jedi a few months ago now we're getting
this episode installment the TV show
other TV shows
hey I said we saw the featurette and for
this and that made it look even better
so yeah I'm excited to check it out all
right here we go
Avengers infinity war crossed the
billion dollars fastest movie ever to
cross a billion dollars are we surprised
yes
very surprised very surprised that the
18 movie 19 movie build-up the only
movie to break a billion over two weeks
was force awakens yes and that was 12
days I believe so this broke in 11 days
12 days force awakens and if I'm not
mistaken this movie hasn't even opened
up in China yet oh man this is gonna
this might become the highest-grossing
that's talking to town could it be could
it be the highest-grossing movie of all
time I feel like it will just not reach
it honestly because force awakens is
number three in terms of highest
grossing worldwide that had a December
release I don't remember a Titanic and
Avatar but I do remember they didn't
have much competition to go off of the
infinity war is the start of the summer
season it's just a couple weeks we're
gonna get Deadpool - we're gonna get
solo okay now Jurassic world in June
there's just so many movies that are
coming out over the next few weeks and
for a movie to do the number one box
office worldwide you shouldn't have
competition for the next like five weeks
at least if you want to destroy
everything be the only fish in the sea
yeah exactly I doubt it'll actually beat
that benchmark I could be wrong and if
I'm wrong I wouldn't be surprised this
movie is in a lane of its own kind of
and has a totally different repeat
viewing value it's like something like
Deadpool 2 or whatever I imagine people
will watch a number of times but just
the event that this movie is I think
makes it sort of one of those Dark
Knight type things where some people
like I've seen 15 times and the other
thing this has gone for it is the IMAX
viewing experience I'm gonna tell you
guys a little story about what happened
on Thursday there's very few real IMAX
screens in Los Angeles the second time
we watch this we went to an IMAX an AMC
promenade and that
not real IMAX by any stretch it's not it
was 2d format it which is how we want to
see it but it's not real IMAX so I was
like all right I'm gonna throw down 60
bucks for my girlfriend a night to go
watch this at a real IMAX a Universal
CityWalk as that is the best IMAX screen
ginormous sound it's amazing I got there
I didn't realize it they had two
different IMAX's for 3d and 2d I hate 3d
so much 5mr movie start turn my tickets
and I'm like we're gonna get Monday yeah
we're not gonna go on Thursday because
this one we was not shot with 3d cameras
and I hate 3d it for a movie with a
color palette like this I don't want it
to have that darkened look where nothing
is popping at I mean oh yeah soulstone
scenes gonna be real yeah but the thing
is going with that IMAX this movie was
shot with IMAX cameras and there's
people like me we've seen it twice
already for like well I just got a watch
and IMAX though I got watching a real
IMAX screen I mean that's what live in
me I want to see you know tonight green
and avatar did that so much from 3d
sales and the hi max sales so I feel
like this movie has the potential to
beat that I just think it's gonna be
very difficult considering the fact that
movie prices are expensive and movie
pass is getting weirder this is gonna
keep warming yeah we'll see if I'm wrong
I'm wrong and I won't be surprised but I
just I doubt it'll it could be avatar I
think it has the potential to beat force
awakens if anything
yeah for sure and hey I mean this this
leaves only 10 days for solo to get to a
billion speaking of soulstones
this is something that I was like wait a
minute you called this [ __ ] I think a
lot of people like I had a fear in and I
are other people had a similar theory
and the Russo brothers disappointingly
put something out there that it could
have been a surprise for Avengers 4 yeah
I'm a little perplexed that they decided
to clarify this spoilers ahead for this
story we saved it for last because if
you haven't seen infinity war just skip
this part and go to this subscribe
section go to the outro and get reminded
of where we are they have this is gonna
be spoiler talk starting in three two
one here we go
they kind of confirmed a theory about
gomorrah and the soul stone
just quotes I'm reading from them which
I'm kind of surprised they they just
sort of said this like I would have been
less surprised if they said yeah Black
Panther and spider-man will be back yeah
like that wouldn't have been like yeah I
wouldn't have been upset about that yeah
this one doesn't upset me it's just kind
of surprising when Russo brothers have
been so anal about not revealing a
single thing Iowa City press citizen I
believe this is Joe Russo who is talking
talking about the post snap scene when
Thanos sees young Gamora yeah it's a
playa it's a soul stone so orange around
then he's inside the soul stone with the
amount of power that took the snap his
fingers he had a body experience with
Thanos when he goes inside the soul
stone he has kind of conversation with
the younger version of Gamora when asked
specifically if Gamora is alive
within the soul stone because there's
some people who have a theory like
myself that the Avengers including
Gamora are still alive within the soul
stone I imagine Gamora probably has a
different thing about her because she
had a different type of death I feel
like the ashes could be you vanished in
but Gamora died so I feel like she might
be like a different type of person
here's what they said oh yeah she was
the offering to the stone itself is she
alive within the soul stone Joe Russo
hear what he said she is in fact yes
there was an attempt on our part because
we don't like two-dimensional rolls or
three-dimensional villains every villain
is a hero in their own story and as
insanely a psychotic and brutal and
violinist a nose is he's a more complex
tool and if you go on a journey with him
emotionally its care for things and his
complicated for him to execute his plan
and it cost him something he said the
end that it cost him everything and that
was the only thing I love which was
Gamora which is why we put him back with
her at the end I just want to reiterate
the audience a does feel true emotion
even though he is a monster in one way
this is not a spoiler and another way of
his a spoiler what he's saying is well
yeah that scene with young Gamora is
confirmation that Gamora is alive in
there her soul exists in the confidence
but I feel like they could have left
that scene a little bit of a mystery
because not everyone fully understood
that scene at the end of the day that
was still a theory at the end of day
that was still us going does that mean
gomorrah's alive in the soul stone Weiss
you a little kid there's still things to
come
with hypotheses yeah it's one of the
more film ish scenes in the movie it's
one of the less you know obviously
intention scenes yeah from their
position I would be like yeah let people
speculate and let people yeah this is
what is what does that mean and
especially given just the circumstances
of like how that's one of the more
impactful deaths in the movie because it
feels more finite it feels more like a
real death yeah so that also kind of
makes me wonder if they're gonna undo
that too
I think they're on Duga Moore's death I
kind of always felt they would be as
they're doing a guardians 3 and I kind
of like the idea of one of the main
guardians on my personal feeling like
one of the main guardians getting killed
off in infinity war when you could have
completed your trilogy with her so she's
such an essential part it's just the
fact that when he's asked about it he
just goes she is in fact yes she's alive
yeah so now the question lays like how
will Gamora appear in Avengers 4 is she
gonna be a child still maybe they'll go
the baby Groot route and bring her back
yeah and then she's on the Guardians
team again but as a kid it was really
honor to Peter she's still in love with
her yeah he's gonna be her fucked-up dad
yeah I mean like I get all the stuff
he's saying about Thanos here it's just
that kind of wish he didn't go yep so
like yeah I feel like he could have
addressed this without going full bore
into just confirmation yeah yeah that's
a more metaphysical scene I guess so
there are a lot of ways where you could
address this very vaguely in terms of at
least the circumstances regarding um
yeah pacifically yeah cuz this is
clearly like talking about it's about
Thanos his journey and it's about his
emotions yeah because most of it I feel
like you might have accidentally slipped
that yeah or something cuz I mean you
hear it oh yeah like the quote you know
it's kind of like the Trump
administration yeah that's how the
juiciest bits of information coming cool
name is I mean Gamora will definitely be
brought back into our world are they
gonna do their we know alternate reality
thing I don't know I don't know that's
where another video will probably do
some other time and we guys yeah
solos kicking butt the box office
infinity war is dominating will across a
billion put your comments down below and
what do you guys think about Joe Russo
doing this is this like a heavy spoiler
for you guys or you kind of what
ever about it do you wish Joe Russo did
not confirm this are we reading too much
into it
that will get a lot more of those put
your comments down below anyway guys you
can subscribe to the reject nation click
that notification Belka subscribe
buttons don't work you could check us
out on patreon full-length TV show
reactions weekly Q&A is a whole bunch of
goodies over there would love to have
you